so we want to evaluate the definite
integral from 3 to 3 of f of X DX and
we're given the graph of f of X and of y
equals f of X and the area between f of
X and the x-axis over different
intervals well when you look at this you
actually don't even have to look at this
graph over here because in general if I
have the definite integral of any
function f of X DX from let's say a to
the same value from one value to the
same value this is always going to be
equal to 0 we're going from 3 to 3 we
could be going from negative pi to
negative pi it's always going to be zero
one way to think about we're starting
and stopping here at 3 so we're not
capturing any area let's do another one
so here we want to find the definite
integral from 7 to 4 of f of X DX so we
want to go from 7 to 4 so we want to go
from 7 to 4 now you might be tempted to
say okay well look the area between f of
X and X is 2 so maybe this thing is 2
but the key realization is this area
only applies when you have the lower
bound as the lower bound and the and the
higher value as the higher bound so the
integral from 4 to 7 of f of X DX this
thing this thing is equal to 2 this
thing is depicting that area right over
there so what about this where we've
switched it instead of going from 4 to 7
we're going from 7 to 4 well the key
realization is is if you switch the
bounds and this is a key definite
integral property that's going to make
that's going to give you the negative
value so this is going to be equal to
the negative of the integral from 4 to 7
of f of X DX and so this is going to be
negative and we just figured out the
integral from 4 to 7 of f of X DX well
now that is this area f of X is above
the x-axis it's a positive area so it is
going to be so this thing right over
here is going to evaluate to positive 2
but we have that negative out front so
our original
expression would evaluate to negative
two